while rescue teams are continuing the
search for survivors after the latest
Russian strike in eastern Ukraine at
least three people have been confirmed
dead after a rocket attack in the city
of crematorsk another 20 were wounded
chromatosk is in the Donetsk region
where russian-backed Fighters have held
significant territory since 2014.
this is the center of the city Only
civilians live here which is why any
attempts to justify this are futile at
the very least
well let's now speak to Natasha Butler
she's on the ground there in Kiev for us
Natasha another Residential Building hit
now
another Residential Building here it's
an emergency service workers have been
at the scene throughout the night trying
to see if they can find any more
survivors very difficult work that are
having to go through the rubble of this
apartment blog but other apartments are
also damaged uh close by what we
understand is at least three people were
killed and a number of other people were
injured but as I said they do still hope
perhaps that they can pull out some
people from that Rubble well Ukraine's
President Vladimir zielinski he talked
about this latest attack in parameters
in this town in the east of the country
said this is just the sort of thing the
ukrainians are having to deal with on a
daily basis these kind of attacks he
also talked about the fact that fighting
is intensifying in the east of the
country particularly we know around
those key that key city of Bak mud we
are told that there are still hundreds
maybe a couple thousand of civilians
trapped in the city including children
unable to get out because it's simply
too dangerous for the time being
Ukraine's defense ministers also been
talking a bit earlier and he said that
he believes that Russian forces could be
looking at trying to launch a new
offensive a new push in the coming weeks
particularly around the 24th of February
that would Mark a year since Russia
invaded Ukraine and Natasha I see the
government is also very busy at the
moment with a corruption Crackdown as
Ursula Vander lion flies in she is
literally giving a press conference
right next to Vladimir zelenski as we
speak
yes uh Ursula vandelion the head of the
European Union Commission in Kiev ahead
of a key Summit uh on Friday with
Ukraine this EU Ukraine Summit coming at
a time in which Ukraine wants to be part
of the European Union it wants to turn
to the West it says this is part of what
it is fighting for these sort of Western
values for uh democracy uh the European
Union though is likely to send the
message that there is still a lot of
work that needs to be done in order for
Ukraine to reach the criteria to become
a full EU member but nevertheless this
is a show of support from the European
Union uh for Ukraine and what uh
Vladimir zielinski has launched in the
past week or so is a huge
anti-corruption sweep in the country uh
we saw last week a number of top
government officials were resigned or
had to step down in the last 24 hours
for homes and offices of tax officials
Customs officials a prominent Ukrainian
billionaire all searched and raised did
this is part of kiev's efforts to show
the European Union that is trying to do
things like clean up corruption one of
the conditions of joining the block very
interesting Natasha Butler there on the
ground in the Ukrainian Capital Kia for
us thanks so much Natasha